alain barbeau lavalette cinéaste
romancière militante
vous êtes à quelques heures de la côte
peas héros de votre nouveau film la
déesse des mouches africaine impact peut
avoir une présence au festival du film
de berlin pour votre film
mais en fait le festival de berlin c'est
à cannes berlin
c'est comme les plus gros festivals les
plus belle rampe de lancement pour le
pour le cinéma international donc à
partir du moment où se présentait son
film à berlin
il rayonne pilote faut imaginer le
soleil c'est vraiment un rayon ça s'en
va ce sur le reste du globe parce que
les grands amoureux du cinéma sont à
berlin et qu'on va mourir du cinéma va
voir qu'est-ce que berlin choisi de
célébrer ou de mettre à l'honneur cette
année
parlons du roman la déesse des mouches à
feu qui justement c'est là votre film
c'est l'adaptation de ce roman là vous
l'avez lu en une seule nuit et le
lendemain vous avais dit je veux faire
un film avec ça est ce que c'est un coup
de tête vous êtes une cinéaste un peu de
l'impulsion du spectacle
fait rare le thé mais je suis gourmand
de lecture j'écris aussi j'aime j'aime
lire puis mais il ya tout le temps un
film qui se déploie c'est ce que j'aime
de la lecture quand je lis ça pour
beaucoup de monde imaginaire se déploie
plus de 6 des world qu'elle filme sa
frite et puis pour la ds a vraiment fait
ça c'est à dire que je les dévorer en
une nuit
mais quand tu lis ce livre là il ya
quelque chose de tellement authentique
dans la façon dont ça raconte
l'adolescence même si c'est pas la
tienne il ya quelque chose qui est pile
sur le ex au niveau des vertiges au
niveau des expériences amoureuses au
niveau des premières expériences de
drogue on ne fait pas un film qui jugent
l'adolescence est un film qui regarde de
façon frontale de façon juste de façon
complètement attente cette période d'âge
de qui dure mais qui est belle qui est
sensuelle qui est enivrante en fait
moi je suis tombé en amour avec votre
travail en 2007 2008 avec le film le
ring qui m'a vraiment touché ce côté où
vous intéresser beaucoup à l'immense
amas en scène un jeune garçon qui vit
des moments assez difficiles avec sa
famille comment trouvez vous la vérité
en ce moment une grande question comment
trouver la vérité mais je sais que je
suis particulièrement sensible à au réel
en fait le fait que j'ai commencé à
tourner en faisant des documentaires
c'est certain que ça attise la
sensibilité par rapport à ce qui sonne
juste par rapport à ce qui bouge juste
je continue à trouver que le réel
dépasse la fiction
et c'est pour le mieux c'est-à-dire que
quand moi je plonge dans une fiction jeu
côté le réel parce que je les célèbres
parce que je le trouve beau parce que je
trouve je suis profondément touché par
par la ville par les humains qui la
composent
donc quand je travaille à une fiction
je veux au moins essayer de dakota est
là la beauté et la façon dont le réel
peut nous surprendre parce qu'elle
aurait les puissants donc il faut que la
fiction soit aussi puissante que quel
réel
oui la transmission est importante on
dit souvent que la pomme ne tombe jamais
loin de l'arbre dans votre cas c'est
votre mère manon barbeau grande cinéaste
en convoi cinéaste la vérité qui aime
beaucoup les gens qui l'entourent
de quelle façon la mer ont nourri la
fine pointe verte estime en fait mon
père est directeur photo sinon mes deux
parents sont dans son dans le milieu je
pense que comme tout enfant qui qui qui
grandit dans un milieu on commence par
le refuser c'est ce que j'ai d'abord
fait
je vais tout faire sauf du cinéma je
travaillais social j'ai fait beaucoup de
voyages où je me suis impliqué ce soit
dans des projets humanitaires dans les
bidonvilles un peu partout dans le monde
mais ça me rattraper quand j'ai compris
que je pouvais faire du cinéma ancré
dans le social ou dans le politique
quand la caméra pouvait être un outil de
transformation de ou de bouleversement
des mentalités quand j'ai compris que ça
pouvait être un moteur de transformation
là je me suis rallié à la transmission
familiale mettons mais ce qu'est ce que
de beau d'avoir des parents qui sont
dans ce métier là c'est que sam savons
tous ceux très accessible en fait ça
fait partie des discussions
le documentaire la cameron faisait
rapidement partie des discussions
familiales donc ça devient
c'est plus sympa l'inaccessible étoile
c'est il ya quelque chose de très
accessible femmes utile d'aider palpable
en fait
alex barbeau-lavalette j'ai bien hâte de
vous retrouver à la berlinale merci
beaucoup merci attendons d'abord oui